Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain a comedy sci-fi film called
“The World Sinks Except Japan”.
Watch out and take care!
Two Japanese men, Goto and Koga are in a bar after
a long day at work. They make fun of an American
performer singing in a horrible Japanese accent.
Recently, Japan has been flooded with foreigners
from around the world moving into the country. The
president of America is sitting beside the two in
the bar. Hearing them making fun of his people,
the politician interrupts their conversation.
He claims that Japanese people should be patient
with the American immigrants because they are
trying their best to learn the language. Goto
disagrees because language is not the only issue.
He claims that America has the highest crime
rate in the world. Humiliated by the civilians,
the president insults the entire country of Japan
but stops when the president of Japan arrives at
the club. It turns out that all the presidents and
higher officials of the world are in the club.
A flashback shows us Goto with his American wife
Catherine. The two are a happy couple and living
in Tokyo. Goto narrates that the night when he was
enjoying his time with his wife was a horrible one
for the rest of the world. The movement of the
tectonic plates under the earth caused massive
earthquakes and tsunamis. At first, the entire
continent of America sank underwater and only the
rich managed to escape drowning in the ocean.
In a Japanese broadcasting company,
the news spreads like a wildfire, making everyone
panic. The president of America presents his final
statement on the matter through a live broadcast
on a plane. He asks the citizens to keep calm
because the neighboring nations will help them in
time of need. As he talks, a half-dressed woman
serves him a drink, but the president seems
to ignore that. While the country is sinking,
he sings a song about America being the greatest
nation in the world. The Japanese officials watch
the live show in awe. They also find out
that he is heading to a base in Okinawa,
Japan. They are ready to take in American
refugees as a gesture of friendship.
Goto also works in the same office and
is arguing with his wife on the phone.
She wants to return to America because she is
worried about her family in Texas. Little does
she know, the mass of land that was one Texas is
now under the ocean. At the house of parliament,
Professor Tadokoro tells the president about
a mantle plume under the surface of the earth
that still has energy and is ready to erupt. He
begins explaining everything about the mantle but
doesn’t get to the point. When the president asks
him what is going to happen next, he falls asleep
and has to be woken up. After a long chat, he
is about to reveal the conclusion, but at the
same time, their meeting is interrupted.
Somewhere else, Oscar-winning actor, Jerry
Cruising and his actress girlfriend Elizabeth
land in Japan. Although their entire country
has drowned, they seem to be excited about
their new life. Jerry believes that since
he is world-famous, the Japanese film industry
will offer him millions to be in their movie.
Elizabeth is just as excited, so much so that she
can’t help but call Japanese people racial slurs.
They are interviewed by the reports about
the situation in America before they left.
Jerry pretends to be sad but swiftly changes
the subject to his Oscar. Koga is one of the
reporters interviewing them. He asks Jerry to
be in a Japanese drama his broadcasting company
is shooting next month. The actor happily agrees
to be in the show. In the following scene, Goto
returns home to Catherine who is worried about her
family in America. He assures her they are okay
since millions of people have fled to different
parts of Asia and Europe as refugees.
Meanwhile, Koga also reaches home to his wife.
They have dinner together while talking about
the price of food skyrocketing after imports
from the US ended. Koga excitedly tells her
about his meeting with Jerry. They assume that
because of the actors, Japanese cinema will be
as successful as Hollywood. For the first
few weeks, Americans are welcomed to Japan
wholeheartedly. People donate to American refugee
charities and aid them as much as possible.
One day, a man holding bowls of Chinese noodles
falls off a bicycle. As the dish drops into a
ditch, the entire nation of China sinks under the
ocean. Similarly, a woman drops a Baguette on the
ditch causing France and entire Europe to sink.
Eventually, all countries sink underwater, leaving
Japan as the only landmass on earth. Almost ninety
percent of the population of earth die because of
the impact. In addition, the population of
Japan increases at an exponential rate.
It is now a few years later after Japan became
the sole country in the world. The Americans
living in Japan have gone completely broke. Famous
American actors do tricks for Japanese businessmen
for money. The Korean and Chinese presidents
turn into minions of the Japanese president
so he would allow their refugees more freedom.
Somewhere else the professor tells his students
that the tectonic plates still have some energy
left which is very soon going to do something big.
As usual, he explains all the unnecessary details
passionately but forgets to get to the conclusion.
Instead, he dances away from the class, leaving
his students wondering. One day on his way to
work, Goto realizes that his country has more
foreigners than its own people. He is on a train
with hundreds of people and not one Japanese
person in sight. He tries to move around the
crowded place and locks eyes with a Japanese
man. Both of them look at each other knowingly
but can do nothing about the situation.
In addition, the Japanese yen becomes the
strongest currency making any other currency
in the world worth pennies. As the prices of
food hike, the refugees resort to begging,
stealing, and looting. Jerry stars in a
high-budget Japanese movie. People had thought
the rise in the American population would make
the movie a hit. But they soon realize that the
target audience cannot even afford a TV.
Jerry loses his job, along with Elizabeth.
They hand their landlord bundles of US
dollars but because of inflation, it is still not
enough. Eventually, the once Oscar-winning actors
go homeless. In the meantime, the Japanese grow
richer in comparison to most of the population.
Koga and his wife are shown eating different
delicacies like whale and tiger meat. His wife
informs him that she is pregnant. The
couple is overjoyed by the good news,
mostly because the birth of the child will
bring one more Japanese into the country.
The following day on his way to work, Koga sees
Elizabeth and takes her out for lunch. She appears
to be starving as she devours her food and eats
from his plate as well. The actress complains
about not getting any jobs and going homeless.
To make her feel better, Koga claims that he will
find her a job no matter what. However, he knows
that no director wants to cast Americans in their
movies after the disaster with Jerry’s last film.
Somewhere else, the professor is enjoying his time
with foreign women who have agreed to be his
mistresses for money. One of his students is
waiting for him to explain the functioning of the
tectonic plates as the man flirts with the women.
The professor explains his theory using sexual
examples but stops before coming to a conclusion
yet again. When asked about his wife, he
gets mad and chases the student away.
Meanwhile, Elizabeth also turns into a prostitute
to earn money. She charges extra money because of
her status but men do not mind paying. However,
her relationship with Jerry deteriorates because
of her new profession. Goto’s wife Catherine
is furious at the Japanese government for not
providing her people with proper facilities. Since
Goto doesn’t care about the foreign policies,
she gets mad at him as well. On top of
that, he suggests they hire foreign maids
since they are affordable and make you look
rich. Catherine is strictly against the idea
but Goto plans to do it nonetheless. The
actor Jerry, on the other hand, is living
in the streets with the other refugees.
When Elizabeth returns home late from work,
he asks her where she was. She bluntly claims that
she was with a customer. She even suggests he join
the business, asking him to be more productive
since he does nothing all day. They get into a
massive argument amidst which, Elizabeth breaks
his Oscar award that he loved more than his life.
The two break up after the fight. When the crime
rate increases, the president of Japan appoints
the defense general as the head of an anti-refugee
organization. Several soldiers are then sent out
to look for illegal refugees and leave them in the
middle of the ocean in the name of deporting them.
Those who do not follow the law or adjust to
Japan’s way of living will also be deported.
The main aim of the government is to
throw out as many foreigners as possible,
so they will not consider re-checking
the documents, even if a person is
falsely reported to be an illegal immigrant. The
presidents of the other nations know this, hence,
they try to stop the bill. But the Japanese
president is adamant about his decision.
He even makes the other presidents dance to a
kid’s song about Japan’s greatness. Soon, several
illegal immigrants are caught. They start to
complain against each other after the government
offers rice cakes to those who inform them of
the illegal people. Several innocent and legal
ones are also deported because of the rule. Jerry
has started to work for a brothel for money.
One day, Catherine sees him on the sideway and
recognizes him as her childhood celebrity crush.
At first, Jerry thinks she is making fun of
him like everyone. After he finds out that she
is genuinely happy to see him, he opens up to
her about his situation. The policemen find it
suspicious and ask Catherine for identification.
When they see she is a Japanese man’s wife,
they let her go. Catherine hands Jerry the
grocery she had just bought when he says
he has nothing to eat. When Goto returns home
that day, he is welcomed by his foreign maids.
They help him change into pajamas and even go to
the bathroom with him in case he needs something.
Since Catherine didn’t shop for tonight’s
dinner, they couldn’t cook anything.
A furious Goto asks his wife why she didn’t
buy food like she was supposed to. The couple
gets into an argument which escalates when Goto
slaps Catherine. She storms out of the house,
saying that she is leaving him. The following
day, Goto happens to see her on his way to work.
She is arguing with the deportation police who
are trying to take Jerry away. Goto interferes
and asks her why she is trying to save a stranger.
Catherine then admits that she is in love with
Jerry and wants to go with him, even if it means
ending up in the ocean. Her husband is shocked
but he can do nothing to change her mind.
In a bar, the presidents of China and Korea are
dancing to entertain the president of Japan. They
have completely given up on fighting for equal
rights for their people. Instead, they now dance
for the president in hopes that he will provide
them with food and shelter. The waiters of the bar
seem to be planning something in secret as they
hand each other parcels. One of them brings out
a gun from a flush tank that they have smuggled.
They take the weapons to the president’s cabin and
hold them hostage. Soon, they take over the entire
bar and hold everyone at gunpoint. Koga and Goto,
who were there to get a drink, are shocked.
The waiters then reveal that they are actually the
North Korean leader and his soldiers who plan to
rule Japan. The Japanese president says that their
defense general is not going to let that happen
since their military is bigger than North
Korea’s. Meanwhile, the defense general is also
held hostage by North Korean spies. Seeing that
he is about to die, he detonates an explosive,
blowing up the entire building. Back at the
club, the dictator is celebrating his victory
when professor Tadokoro appears riding on a kid’s
tricycle out of nowhere. He tells them about the
tectonic plates yet again. However, this time, he
completes his sentence and reveals that in only a
few minutes, Japan is also going to sink under
the sea, ending the existence of mankind.
Right after he gets done, a massive earthquake
hits. Everyone falls to the ground and starts
praying for their lives. People fight with each
other for no reason since everyone is going
to die anyway. Suddenly, the lights go off. The
people in the club come together to light a candle
and gather around it. In the background, it is
narrated that at least in the last moment, world
peace exists. Soon, another earthquake hits which
makes the land of Japan sink under the ocean. At
last, no humans are left on earth.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out. Thank You for watching.